when i trained when i trained kung fu
and karate
here we go i apologize hey my mouth do
you like to go by what
uh shinigami is fine what's your what's
your real name uh danny
danny yeah
i mean technically yeah technically yeah
one of the reasons where you're here is
when you know chappelle's my feature so
when we're on the road we
get a big airbnb with all our boys and
someone always be like oh you gotta
check out this video check out this
video
and chappelle's like dude you gotta see
this guy you gotta see this guy so we're
in houston
and you you went especially when it's
fighting like oh god and because we'll
meet some random kid and back dude he's
a boxer i'm like that kid's not a boxer
i don't know fighting too yeah so he's
like yes you guys see this guy who got
me man you gotta see this guy
so he clicks on it i'm like what is this
and it's like you know backyard fight
and then and they're
[Music]
regular point sparring tournaments i was
like finally able to put the pepper on
it and just
i was kind of shocked myself man my
favorite part of that video is the kid
obviously you go low kick and i'm like
oh he sent his ass up low kick
and then you see him like reach down for
the kick and then boom and then you see
him go
[ __ ] yeah yeah
that's that that is
i saw that too i'm like oh yeah well you
know what you know you should have tried
to grab the cake
do you do any do you do any boxing as
well or um yeah uh i've dabbled in
boxing a little bit for mma uh
been taking muay thai classes like the
last month see what i like about you
is that it'd be very easy to be sensei
shinigami and just have your
school and and have your con you're
sparring that's very you know points
barring
this is karate but you you've got this
following you got your students and you
were willing to get into a
pit and put it to the test you could
have looked stupid you could have gotten
knocked out you haven't been
oh that's that's what i like about you
thanks
that's what i thought was going to
happen but uh you did it no i didn't
i really
uh i'm like 288 right now you were
bigger than that video though i was like
yeah i was like 330 pounds dude like
pandemic weight was not fun dude yeah
how does this
how does one get into that street
fighting stuff um like how's this come
about
so i've been watching street beef since
like 2010 hell yeah right
um so i ended up uh
finding out that like when they posted a
video they were going to do a west coast
event like in 2019
and i wanted to try to get into that
like scarface came out here and did a
thing like right up north from where i'm
at
and uh i couldn't make it but then they
started an actual west coast group
like a west coast branch and i i joined
the group on facebook
and got in like i got it in the last
second actually because there was a
little misunderstanding with uh because
you know
facebook's stupid with the timeline feed
crap like
you don't get all the notifications
unless you really like find a way to set
it that way
um so i missed a bunch of group
notifications that it was actually going
to be in california it was supposed to
be like
in california they got moved to vegas
and i thought it was canceled altogether
and then i found out like the morning of
that it was in san bernardino
so i hit up tiny tank and was like hey
man please just give me a shot i really
want to try
to do some full contact fighting for
once and next thing i know i'm down
there
knocking detail out you know just wax
detail got waxed did they uh
do you have to like uh give them like
your background like i have a black belt
in this like trained in this or is it
just
they try to match you up based on like
your experience but a lot of guys just
like they aren't trained in like belt
arts or whatever so it's just street
fighter yeah it's a lot of
street fighters i mean there's a lot of
most of the guys on the west coast are
trained but they're training like boxing
kickboxing wrestling stuff like that not
all i mean there's a few of us that are
like jiu jitsu karate
but do you know what the opponent what
they specialize in no
you don't have any ideas
you tell you know you tell the guys
running the event what your experience
level is and what everything is and then
depending on who actually shows up
because there was like five guys that
didn't show up that signed up and said
they were yeah
that's actually how i was able to get in
because there was like at that point
there was two guys that had quit they're
cancelled
they probably see that black belt like
[ __ ] this
like
i mean this is a custom one i got just
for street views because my sensei was
like yeah don't
don't mention the dojo because we aren't
really that kind of dojo right now
okay okay let me ask you this if you
don't mind elaborating on this
uh as far as payment goes is it run like
you know oh no they don't pay you no no
it's like even on the youtube views
nothing you know
you you have like 20 million views on
that
damn video one million of them from the
twitter
3.9 on the detail video 1.4 on this the
stormrider video
you should get money for that um it
doesn't work that way b
it doesn't it doesn't oh i'm sorry no i
mean it doesn't work it's like
it's like any amateur or basically i
mean that's how they kind of stay legal
they don't pay us
and there's no they don't charge you
yeah there's no commission but is it
still
is it illegal oh so that's that's how
that's how they get around yeah they're
exhibitions and they're um they don't
pay us they don't charge people to show
up the only people really get to show up
as a fighter plus one or plus two
depending on
the situation the pandemic and
everything that kind of stripped it down
to plus one
but um no payment whatsoever interesting
for sure yeah but then the organization
if we can call it that
street beefs they're they're not
charging ticket sales either no
they're just doing it for the content
yeah like it's
it's a forum for anyone who wants to
test themselves out to do it and
first and foremost it's a way for people
to settle like disputes
without doing stupid stuff like shooting
each other stabbing each other
oh these are real disputes some of them
are some of them
the further back you go the more beef
fights there are yeah
now it's kind of mostly competition but
there's still beef fights
there are still fights i didn't know
that oh yeah i thought it was just like
they just
oh yeah i know it wasn't real uh
scarface started out just putting fliers
up in like local like
bodegas and bars and stuff like that
just you know hey
cause because i guess one day somebody
had come to his his house and asked if
they could fight in his backyard
to settle a beef and he he's been
through a lot of stuff in his life too
you know so he's seen all
the you know where all that stuff can go
in the hood people shooting each other
yeah oh god
i mean there was a beef that was
literally over twenty dollars twenty
dollars yeah twenty dollars but it was
the principal there's one
principle of it there i mean that's
actually one of the best ones i can't
remember what their names were but
it's an older video they were literally
in his backyard with just like the
plywood
and no barrier yeah it's very lion heart
growing up
lion heart was my favorite moment so i
came there if i came then i was like the
the white guy in the suit like trying to
get money rolling would they allow that
or no
like i can't benefit no no that's no
strictly no money i mean he ain't gonna
say it on the podcast
oh yeah it's true i'm sure if you want
to wait your b can get a little action
man yeah
come talk to the kid yeah you know what
i'm saying
yeah matching white suits just like that
you're the guy we're just here to watch
now if you want to get paid you'd have
to
i mean you could talk to him it'd be
like it'd be like white man can't jump
we bring you in as like the
the smoker you know you just take them
no he's talking
about white man can't kiss what happened
i like that
and this is this little thing you want
to fight this little
thing yeah douche yeah he's not gonna he
doesn't know he's not excited nobody
take it easy on him no
now did that did street beefs did it
start in florida
it started in virginia virginia yeah
that's where the main branch is in
virginia
but it's really big out here yeah it's
huge out here i mean it's it's only been
like a year and every time there's a
sign up post there's like 300 people
signing up
damn really 300 now they select they're
very selective
though i mean not anybody could just get
down the one next month is
going to be 25 fights so they're
selecting 50 fighters that's only did
they make it take a covet test and watch
it
uh they don't make it
everybody's pretty pretty good about
that there's everyone yeah yeah yeah
everyone gets their tests before they go
i mean
i i haven't testified you know there's
there's been a couple of guys are like i
got to pull out because i tested
positive for kovid
and so people are honest about it yeah
how much yeah trust system uh
how how much uh time do they give you
before a fight like do you do a real
camp
oh you just like [ __ ] it uh i mean i'm
constantly training so
yeah i feel yeah that's what's gonna say
um yeah for sure training his life
um but yeah i mean some guys make sure
they they train for a couple months
before signing up
how many fights have you had uh in
street views i've had five that's a lot
five and a half five you know he's five
and oh how old are you 34. you look
young
i know you look so young everybody tells
me man i got that young thing
34. yeah 34. we're the same age 87
yep yeah march 27 1987.
so how do they uh as far as the the
arena goes or like the the ring i guess
sometimes i'll see it on grass sometimes
i see dirt sometimes i see hay which i
was frowned upon so like scrap yard and
the og yard have like a set location
that they fight at all the time
um but the west coast moves around uh
between california arizona and nevada
uh so more people can you know have a
chance to fight so that's kind of what
dictates what the terrain is like
depends on who's whose house is
right oh no there's weight classes yeah
unless it's a beef bite then there's no
weight classes
and do you do you know what what's up
because what's happening because you
were three thirties
uh yeah heavyweight in street beefs is
like 2 30 and up
that's fantastic 225 and up yeah there's
this guy called i think
they call him lil hulk baby hulk baby
hulk he's a yeah he's a big black dude
yeah little
he he fights like he'll fight anybody so
sometimes some guys again i'm like why
would you sign up for this dude how do
you think
oh
[Music]
that's that's is hulk that's baby baby
baby holds the champ right looks like
kevin hart yeah yeah actually he just he
just signed pro so he's uh
he's out of the yard and he's moving on
yep
yeah i think he's gonna be doing pro mma
other than he beats him wow he's
dude i'm pro boxing you're probably i
can't remember which he's explosive look
at him
rico are both uh pro two and i actually
have an offer from fury fc after i do
this uh big smile rematch
is is that the uh goal for for most guys
in in street beefs to move on to a
bigger
like legit organization some of us some
of us uh i don't
know if i say most i think most of the
guys are just doing it for fun it's like
oh it's like tough man have you thought
about a hobby you know have you thought
about
getting crazy about cutting weight and
and fighting it like i don't know
because like yeah i've actually been
down to like 250 before uh
just uh i actually had an injury i took
like a month and a half training off
like this last month and a half so i'm
just barely getting back in like twice a
day training and everything what's the
lightest you think you could get if you
had to really do it probably like 235
oh really because you wouldn't be a
heavyweight yeah yeah just a sure
what are you right now uh 288 288 so
you're just a heavy weight
so how old are you though uh six two six
two
that's not bad june 25th so when we
watch the videos and me not knowing i
like this probably went that cardio
can't be nice
you know like your car you know
yeah how long are the the rounds two
minutes two minute round your cardio is
pretty good though
yeah that's why like i like looking i'm
like oh he better get it done quick so
we watch the first one
kick some [ __ ] dude right in the face
like jesus christ we go on the next one
it goes all three rounds
but yeah the car it wasn't you submitted
it it wasn't great oh you got him an arm
lock
yeah i got him with the with the
americana how much jiu-jitsu training do
you have
i'm a blue belt so what like two three
years uh actually i've got more than
that
i'm about like nine years but it wasn't
all in the gym you know
gotcha you know jiu jitsu is expensive
you guys use an expensive yeah
class so uh for a couple of years i
really didn't have the money for it so i
was just like
i would hook up with guys that i was
chad used to train with like at their
house rolling in the garage on mats no
you can learn a lot
from just keep the rust off yeah yeah
can't you learn a lot from youtube too
if you watch the right
if you watch the rest of and have
someone to try it on um
like i would i'd suggest going to uh i
would yeah
i would have just going but i feel like
there's so many instructional videos on
youtube
but like the gracies have the online
university yeah
the gracie university for sure but you
gotta be here you gotta be in class you
gotta be in it
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's always better
to be you know in
in class where you're like it's like
that acting class you talking that's the
topic
i can kill it i watch breakdowns of
tennis strokes
and i do literally everything they do
break it down i took a class
this woman who was a competitive player
and she goes she goes she goes
left stop everything what are you doing
i'm watching youtube she goes this is
what drives me crazy
all my students got to because i've been
watching youtube you can't learn that
way
it's not and i'm like but i was brave no
there's a there's a reason why i have
yet
there's certain things you can learn on
youtube though yeah you can learn guitar
you can use it as a supplement you you
can get stuff you can
yeah you can get some information off of
youtube but i definitely recommend you
go train with people who know what
they're doing otherwise you're going to
need that dentist in the box you tried
to sell on that
you're right yeah i grew up watching
this guy man
um so so for you it's just about
you it's for you so your background's in
what though uh temple shotokan karate
let's take a little break with the
street panda himself
because guess what man you ever feel
like living a healthy lifestyle it's
hard man you try so damn hard to keep up
what is considered
healthy all right you push yourself
every day getting better and better but
it can be overwhelming
you just want to reach for a nice cold
beverage but you want
all the calories and sugar oh cool coors
pure
is here fam and since it's all organic
has zero sugar you can enjoy it without
feeling guilty all right coors pure is
organic but they're chill about it
nude of course pure cool it's refreshing
simple bear with organic barley organic
hops and water
only 92 calories zero sugar is the
perfect bear to celebrate the winds of
every life
every day alright get it going man don't
be
out of shape thick be a cool in shape
thick all right
so when you're ready to start uh
celebrating the winds of life
every day all right when you want to
enjoy a nice cold bear without the guilt
reach for coarse pure it's organic but
they're chill about it
go to coorspure.com to see where you can
find coors pier
uh celebrate responsibly coors brewing
company albany georgia
cbd i keep telling you kids this it's
the wild west that there you know who to
trust
or maybe getting from a site you get it
from a store off venice beach and
they don't have shoes on they're wearing
sandals or they're barefoot you're like
i guess i chose the cbd
or maybe you're getting a name brand one
but is it the name brown one take all
the guesswork out
i got something for everybody direct
temp it's the amazon of cbd all right
you can choose from dozens dozens of the
top products multiple brands
and get everything shipped in one
convenient box everything you order
is online directly from direct temp
website all right
they also have great customer service
they have all the brands
that i love and that you guys love on
one simple
shopping site we're talking about direct
temp customer service is 24
7. what do you whatever you have
whatever questions you got we got you
covered at direct temp
they have 100 satisfaction guaranteed
all right
uh you can follow them on social media
to learn more whatever you're looking
for go to directhemp.com promo code is
thick for 10 off but we have a big sale
going on
this weekend memorial day sale go check
them out we're talking about
crazy sales on the top cbd products
it's this weekend only from memorial day
directamp.com promo code
thick for 10 20 off certain items
go to directamp.com promo code thick
with three c's t-h-i-c-c
dragtempt.com um so
so for you it's just about you it's for
you
so your background's in what though uh
temple shotokan karate
i'll say you've been doing that since a
kid uh no i actually didn't start
training in anything until i was 20.
it's not too bad what was your sport
before that nothing
uh truth be told i was never really into
sports or athletic stuff like at all
um before doing martial arts i hate
working out just to work out it's
boring and it drives me nuts you don't
want to be the best what made you say
i want to start fighting like yeah what
made you say but just not any fighting
right you're [ __ ] a guy who fought
at a high level dude when i see what you
guys doing like jesus christ
like there's no there's no medical you
know like
the the the the refs like [ __ ] it out
let's get it on me is like tattoos
[Laughter]
it's like jesus christ like when we you
know kimbo was in the house to be a good
friend of mine
and just watching his videos you're like
oh my god like obviously all of us came
up
the traditional way and organizations
you know local shows then got to the
higher level
and but kimbo like everyone had such i
would say even more respect for him
because he came up from the
literally from the [ __ ] backyards and
that now his the way he did was wrong i
mean
that was like real illegal underground
fighting where they were paying him and
everything
he was fighting one he was fighting this
one dude and the dude's pinkie's broken
and dude's going like i'm done i'm done
and they're not stopping and still suck
him in the face
so kimbo just kept beating them like
you're not far off from that man
i know yeah you were fighting a guy and
you had hay all over you
oh yeah dude i actually that that
rematch i actually lost to the hay bales
where i lost the dude
yeah like i was like tripping over the
hay bales i'm like okay well that's the
thing like if you don't know what ground
it is
you're doing like those sliding kicks
and stuff you can you can
how's your family feel about you doing
this backyard um
like the first one really like hey mom
are you married girlfriend
uh rachel was cool with it uh she's
always supported my martial arts career
in fact actually she started paying for
my jiu jitsu training about like mma
training back in the day like
that's like a long story they're like
nah now rachel i could get into the
whole
rachel is your girlfriend yeah yeah you
got it yeah sorry
rachel uh she has a kid and so i i'm a
step dad yeah i'm a step dad but i mean
i treat you like she's my own kid you
know yeah you probably kick ass at it
yeah yeah it's awesome he was getting
those we had a question about one of her
types
of phrases oh yeah i stopped okay
no no no no no so that's just that's
that's a that's a wicked tattoo
oh all right that's like the wicked
chicken
witch i'm i'm an atheist myself so you
know it is what it is you but you
obviously
since you don't get paid for kicking
guys in the face you also have a day job
uh not right now do you teach arts
um i was teaching martial arts part of a
park program volunteering
um when i was a good parent
my goal is to open my own school like my
goal right now like short term is go pro
save up some money open my own school
and like teach full time for the rest of
my life
do you have any experience in wrestling
uh i've seen you try dribbling
wrestling judo throws and stuff yeah
i've um
just jiu-jitsu all that all that stuff
comes from i've never i didn't wrestle
in high school or nothing
yeah and they do nothing in high school
nothing
uh i used to get kicked out of school a
lot uh for
fighting uh not in high school
uh but i what did you do
we're gonna find out he just got out of
jail i used to get in five don't don't
get me wrong i used to get
fights in high school i used to get
picked on a lot but um i didn't get
kicked out for fighting
uh actually i got kicked out in ninth
grade because this dude down the street
uh they used to pick on me middle school
my dog would get out and go in his yard
and one time
he said that if she got in his yard
again he was going to shoot her with his
bb gun
and he did it because there was like a
some kind of mark on her after he held
so
i was having a bad day one day like just
wrong side of the bed kind of morning
nothing was going right and then i get
in my first period of class and there
had been like some kind of explosion or
something in town
like you could hear it loud it's like a
lot of people this is lancaster lake la
little subsidiary it's like an
unincorporated area a little tiny thing
i walk
in there uh more like meth lab blow ups
back up
i'm thinking breaking bad from you
there was that's definitely not a lot to
do anyway so i walk in in
my first period class and this dude asks
if i heard it and i was in a bad mood so
i was like yeah i was probably you
shooting somebody else's dog
so then we got into an argument and he
was like well
you know next time your dog gets out
i'll shoot her with my 22 and i was like
you shoot my dog i'll shoot you my
teacher heard it and that was that oh
you gotta do it yeah yeah yeah it was
the heat of the moment thing you know
you should have kicked him in the face
yeah you should have if i would have
known i probably would i would just cut
my mouse and kicked him in the face and
probably still would have gone use that
have you ever hit anybody
yeah i don't know right it looks like it
like that is the big that's no
actually that it's been used a lot yeah
so that is i used to get out of the the
restaurant job i would have like the
middle of the night
and i put it on top of my car before i
got in the car and a couple of times i
drove off with it on the roof
oh and you go back and get it and it
would i would i wouldn't know until i
heard it fly off and explode in the
middle of the street so then i have to
go way up
it'll shut down that'll shut the road
down yeah it's a barrel of [ __ ]
water just water these days i saw on
your uh twitter people are telling me
you were you posted you're having car
problems
yeah what's going on with it uh well i
did i had to get some repairs and then i
had to put it on the credit card because
like 500 bucks it was something stupid
easy
it was like uh spark plugs and a valve
cover gasket
but they they they 95 an hour
labor decided to take three hours to
figure it out and then another so
did you get a figure because i saw you
had a gofundme yeah
um it's almost there i was like 440.
so what's the total of four seventy
three forty i'll cover that for you for
doing the show oh thank you guys so much
man yeah yeah um you're awesome yeah
yeah so you
drive down here in that yeah you go down
here in it yeah oh cause it's already
fixed yeah
i i got it fixed i just had to i had to
um because i you know i needed to get
around the trainings i had to put her on
the credit card though you know
yeah no i got you man yeah no yeah you
drove all the way down here
come on man you get all the way down
here so do you watch a lot of fighting
are you kind of
the guy that stays away from it i
haven't in a while because i've been too
busy training and stuff
and uh but i used me and rachel used to
go to sports bar all the time actually
i actually got her into watching
fighting we started school sports bar to
watch ufc we'd go watch you fight you
can watch machida fight
all those guys you've been you've been
with your lady for how long uh
well it's twenty twenty so like uh seven
years long eleven years
that long time yeah y'all don't wanna do
the married life uh that's not really my
thing
i just don't think anyone should have to
you know need a piece of paper
and the government involved in a ring to
tell each other they love each other
agree
not my it's not my fault um so the goal
is to do
to do this rematch and when is it is it
next month to be it was supposed to
originally be next month now it's
supposed to be in july i believe what
are you going to do
where is it in july uh it's going to be
here in like ohio god we should go to it
yeah you guys are more than welcome how
are you will you let us know when the
official date
oh yeah for sure as soon as i know you
guys will know yeah what are you what
are you going to do differently
to see if i don't want to give away the
game
that's where you got he got need about
that i didn't lose that fight by the way
it was a draw you didn't no okay
see he celebrated too early there was a
there was an issue the crowd has never
been that loud and the ref thought he
heard someone yell time
30 like 15 seconds early because he just
said 30 seconds
and then he thought he heard someone
yell time so he stopped the round a
little early and big smile thought he
won
i was fine those knees didn't even hurt
look there you go
so uh it ended up going another day the
full three rounds
and ended in a draw so that's why
there's a rematch
but um yeah man like i was fine
in ohio ohio is like a nice yeah we're
like
up hours away oh yeah it's kind of far
right now we're at 40.
it's an hour 40 years now and 40. yeah
but you know it's in a nice little it's
on a fast
little cage
uh
you know it's funny barefoot farmer
actually made like a really nice
professional cage with mats and
everything
but that's too professional looking for
street views i want to keep it unique i
agree with that
yeah i want it more like so right next
to it
they put a little tinier like a slightly
smaller cage
with sand in it right next to it and
there's like hay
and like pigs over here i wonder i
wonder why oh out of all the spots in
cali ohio
because one of the uh street beast
fighters uh
has a farm and has a big old huge
property yeah oh got it
yeah he's even got like a little gym in
a little garage like oh he's balling
like just
yeah so explain to me what happened the
first match
you guys were it was a draw so now
you're going to have the rematch yeah
and do you think are you going to i
guess it was a draw right i
had you went in that yeah i mean i felt
like i edged it out but
you know it is what it is what are you
gonna do differently uh well you know
what you don't want to do that
man i'm not gonna i'm not gonna give the
game i'm not damn i'm not throwing the
game
away but i will say this i definitely
feel like i way overestimated his skills
the first fight
and now that i got a better feel for it
uh he's a tough kid but
um like i watched all those other fights
you know i thought his ground and pound
was gonna be harder than it was
and uh i thought his pressure was like
his weight was gonna be more than it was
like no
uh i expected his striking power to be
more than it was and his grappling power
to not quite
like it was the other way around like he
grabbed my leg and it was like a vice
grip and i'm like oh okay
here we go like the guy i trained with
phil which by the way he went nuts when
he found out i was going to be on here
he watches you guys all the time he's
just uh
he's one of my training partners uh
filthy phil the beast dude's huge
that dude is way stronger than a big
smile so i was training with him and i
couldn't i could
i managed to keep him from taking me
down for five minutes at a time yeah so
i thought i'd be fine with big smile i
didn't think vic smile was gonna be
anywhere near as strong as he had that
single but he
he got that first one nice and deep i
mean granted you know
i went straight to that omoplata attack
but you know
i i did not expect that grip to be like
that but his his strikes were
you uh you get you get nervous before
the fights
um i try not to uh mostly i don't
sometimes like that one i was
like that one was kind of like my first
one i didn't get nervous until they said
fight that yeah oh fight yeah i mean
that was your first fight
uh no no no no like the okay so i've
been crying tournaments for over a
decade
oh god so i'm used to being across from
people i don't know who i'm fighting i
don't know i
yeah in fact one time i ended up
fighting this dude who had only been
training for like six weeks they pulled
they literally pulled him into this dojo
off the street because he was
like jacked right this dude had no
control this dude uppercutted me to a
table he literally uppercutted me so
hard i was off the ground and flew onto
the judge's table
hell yeah yeah so i mean he ended up
getting disqualified
um well no i mean they always continue
sparring technically they're loud he
just did it too hard yeah
right because it's supposed to be like
light contact sparring
and uh so i got used to dealing with all
kinds of all kinds of competitors
that i didn't know who i was fighting
until i showed up that day so i'm like
okay street beef's gonna be the same
thing the only difference is now i get
to
i mean yeah maybe they knocked me out i
don't know who i'm fighting it could
happen
not gonna let it happen if i can help it
so i get there and i'm in there and then
i realize
after i'm like while i'm waiting to do
my intro i'm like okay
this is really happening i really i
really did this i drove down here and i
don't know who's going to see what
happens
and then as soon as i said fight i'm
like okay this is unreal
as soon as i said fight the butterflies
came and i hadn't felt those in over a
decade and i'm like oh
there you go all right and then i threw
the low kick and he drops his hands to
black and i'm like
okay all right i'm gonna fake low and if
he drops his hands again i'm going okay
in the face yeah i didn't think that was
i didn't i didn't expect it to knock him
out
like that yeah but it did oh and then i
was just like okay
i wish they would have shown cause my
daughter was actually there she was the
real the great tank top
when i saw that fight yeah that's what i
was like oh this guy's a real dude
that's what sold everybody on me even
the people that were there were like
heckling me and stuff like i didn't
really hear it yeah if you actually
watch that fight
do you hear like get him ryu get a duke
and like
and then after i knocked the dude out
like it's the second one yeah that's the
second one yeah 3.9 million views yeah
i feel like you should be getting paid
for that i mean i got a lot of
experience oh but this isn't
okay i mean look he's he's here today
yeah
and they give you guys vaseline oh yeah
you're way bigger there
to california oh yeah martial arts yeah
did you warm up in the back do you warm
up in the back before this yeah i was in
there's my daughter right there in the
great school you don't seem nervous at
all
she's nervous for you right well uh i
don't i don't know if she was nervous or
what
she probably didn't know what i wish i
wish i could right behind
like literally directly all right here
we go
here we go and now who whose gloves are
those did you bring them to the event
you can bring whatever gloves you want i
mean they inspect them first but yeah as
long as they're are they four ounces
yeah
booms yeah he goes i love you
[ __ ] yeah so i know he's all hyped
look at you was that your quickest
knockout it's a quick
yeah that'd be tough so that that's
pitfall right there right no that's not
pit bull
that's that's crazy aka master roshi
uh yeah let us see his uh highlight tape
so is that a common uh thing like to
kind of
trick that kick fake low and go high oh
yeah that's a common yeah a lot of times
you do question mark kicks yeah so it
goes like this and goes around
uh-huh oh okay then like with karate and
like taekwondo and stuff the
the kicks are a little snappier they're
not as like uh
loaded or like with more side kicks you
kind of like switch not knockout shots
well it's not so much that they're not
knockout shots but like what the whole
thing with like karate kicks is they
they load up and snap out so you can
actually use once you bring your knee up
you can change
to any kick you want oh yeah so that's
kind of like the trick i can
go low or like you know fake a front
kick and then go high
you know to the round house before you
know because they think you know you set
them up with one cake
and then over the top it goes the next
time let's see this highlight reel
i put this together real quick because i
got home super late from from with that
class last night
yeah my thing is i want to show the fans
all your highlights but
we can't use on youtube because the d
monetize the show right yeah yeah
because
we don't own the content right ready oh
yeah
are you ready some of these are old
tournament stuff
that last one would have hit him man if
i was slitting just a little bit
oh shoot up throw
[Applause]
boom damn
he couldn't take you down i threw that
in there because i i i gave him a little
bit oh you you rocked that you [ __ ]
this guy up you [ __ ] this
guy he was scouting it out
oh
yeah i felt like it was sleeping out
watching it it wasn't slipping out i was
using it for a sweep though that was
good
damn
yeah this is you get it right here yeah
oh that's nice there you go there you go
there you go
oh you tried your moves
well he tried to get him too and he
ended up hitting my elbow
and i had this huge bump for about two
weeks and his foot's still not right
oh yeah oh yeah i could hear them
heckling you i heard they're the duke
yeah yeah they were heckling you oh some
somebody
you're not supposed to record but
somebody was in the back recording and
they uploaded it to instagram like two
months ago
because they don't want to and it was
like a 30 minute video and i skipped to
the part where i was about to fight and
they're sitting there talking all kinds
of smack right
[ __ ] and no it's funny though because
they did what everybody else did
see they're sitting there talking smack
like man dude i got like 100 bucks a
karate dude gets his freaking head
knocked off right
blah blah blah blah blah really or gets
taken down easy
and then after i knocked you down
they're like oh crap i was wrong
so then i fought again the same day when
i fought storm rider that was the same
event
because he actually got beat by wa like
really quick and they call it a cko and
he felt like he wasn't done yet like
he was he was actually mad they stopped
it early so he wanted to fight again
because he felt like he had more to show
i drove two hours and knocked a dude out
in like four and a half seconds and was
like
well i kind of feel like i got more to
show and he was trying to find somebody
else to fight
and eventually just came down to me and
him it was like 115 degrees
damn some one guy had already gotten
like
overheated yeah so they were actually
they'd actually just called it
and said we're not doing any more fights
and storm i was like no i'm gonna fight
again i'll fight again and he said he'd
fight me
so that was right after the yeah so they
were like
but it's too hot he's like dude i'm from
west texas and i'm like man i'm from
lancaster
115 degrees i'm used to it yeah yeah so
next thing you know we go at it and i
was actually trying to like
make it go to the second round then i
was gonna like because i i could i'm
sitting there looking at all the ways i
could have tapped them out in that first
fight
granted he told we talked and he was
like well man did i haven't trained in
eight years no so is
is there a heavyweight champ like a
reigning heavyweight champ right now
you're the champion for the west coast
right now for the west coast
east coast champion that would be a big
smile so that was why that's what we
wanted to fight it was a mega fight
see when i first they give you a belt
um the west coast hasn't had their belts
made they do have a west coast belt on
the east coast because originally
they had one made for red reaper he was
the first west coast reaper
yeah he's not and you're you're what
reaper you got me should have gotten but
you also
that's basically what shinigami is the
equivalent of in japanese
i like to call you street panda i saw
that
you know how much merch you would sell
as street pants i i do need to make a
street panda shirt now do it man
definitely everything i rocked the [ __ ]
out of it for me
like when when i saw you in the ghee the
whole get up i was like oh this dude's
serious
yeah i did i didn't underestimate you at
all i like i was like if that's why you
[ __ ] with him
yeah cause i was like if he showed up in
that yeah i was like oh he's a real deal
yeah
i was like he's not messing around and
then you did the kick and i was like
sold
so yeah it's funny too because there's a
bunch of people who have uh like made
uh commentary videos on youtube and
stuff or like whatever and like half of
them were like this guy looks like he's
throwing mcdojo down the street but then
he just
knocks his dude in fact even pat mc pat
mccaff
mcafee mcafee i don't want to pronounce
his name wrong no i got it wrong for
years he's a good friend
pat mcafee uh was like he looks like
he's from the dojo down there's like
karate school
in the store down the street you know
and then he comes out and he kicks you
in the head
yeah i love it oh so that [ __ ] went on
like viral like that
yeah oh yeah hell yeah oh yeah in fact
i didn't know which you guys wanted me
to wear but uh i don't know if you saw
the intro from that one but he actually
sponsored me that fight oh
that's awesome hey for your fight in
july we should find the kids should
sponsor you here we go
yeah absolutely that's a great idea
that's a great idea i want a i want a
street panda shirt man
i'll have to i don't know yeah yeah i'll
help you with that yeah
sweet street panda yeah you have merch
right now don't you yeah i got i got
merch on um teespring
who oh so do you uh design yourself in
this update
yeah well i have a guy who made a logo
for me um
which is the the logo you saw on that
one rashgar which is what i'm wearing
right now actually i got it i had that i
had customers wait which one
uh
panda would crush that's intense and
then the heart and the fight went up top
that's
i have a collab with them i get a
percentage of anything they sell the one
with my face on it
which one yeah those that yeah that's
hard in the fight they're actually
really involved with street beasts now
dude that's awesome yeah i need this
what do i do we all need it i know right
you don't eliminate this i need
a street panda [ __ ] i got i i've got
i've got the
oh that's right oh yeah
you're the real see i knew i [ __ ] with
you i knew it i'm ordering that shirt
when i get out of here yeah right
what does shinigami mean uh god of death
god damn right it does god of death does
something
does someone give you that name um no i
gave it to myself see
um one person can have
nothing i gave myself that uh so i was
going by reaper forever yeah
right uh before that and there's already
the reaper grim reaper red reaper and i
couldn't think anything else to use in
street beasts a lot of reapers
so i went with shinigami because i've
been learning
japanese on and off since i was like six
oh [ __ ]
so uh you know studying japanese culture
just like
that's godzilla got me into that just
stopping but
this is my favorite one no i was worried
about the whole thing
yeah i've been i love japanese off and
on since i was six which is
not true but i know what you mean and
then i love you and you're awesome
yeah but he goes no brian fancies
himself with the condo master
i'm [ __ ] with you but he goes you say
that and brendan goes
makes sense
[Applause]
how good is your japanese be serious be
honest um
he's been doing this training
everything about you so you can never
dude i've been i've been training and
fighting too long i haven't i've been
studying japanese
practice but all of these are gonna have
to speak japanese that makes sense what
you're saying makes sense
uh when i go to japan eventually um have
you been there yet no but i plan to do
take these street skills to japan
yeah man tumble some of the boys
fighting organization in japan
underground um no it's not underground
but stay underground it's like it's like
a once a year now but it's so cool dude
really
so we're gonna shut up chin how do you
spell that
wouldn't you assume like
please
is
cat looks like she's going to stop
youtube man
it's like this different version of mma
where it's like on a plat it's like on a
raised platform with like no barriers
uh-huh
and you only get like 15 seconds on the
ground here we go here we go
that top one yeah you have to wear a
ghee
you have to work here can you submit it
with again that's your world yeah you
can these dudes are
serious you get 15 seconds on the ground
like a judo match you're [ __ ]
but you can also you can also win by
pushing them off the ring three times
oh like sumo stuff yeah dude that's
katsuru kikuno
you know who that is it makes a badass
oh really okay
i was fighting here like three times oh
wow these guys are real funny who's that
you don't know who marcus cereal is
i'm i'm new to the world you don't know
listen i discovered you okay
and like a black belt in brazilian jiu
jitsu
he is knocked out people in mma fights
doing capoeira
yeah and in this he he did like a
cartwheel
like leg grab like
flipped the judo [ __ ] damn dude
oh [ __ ] there it is there it is and so
you want to you want to eventually do
that
i would love to go do that do they have
heavy weights
yeah well that's a mountain right there
there's some problems here yeah
i think this guy is just muay thai
because he has no idea how to get out of
here
he's just getting his ass kicked yeah
he's doing everything wrong
that [ __ ] ref though look at that
outfit man i know that's a sleeve oh
yeah i've never heard me i respect you
so [ __ ] much dude
but you probably gotta get into you guys
the real deal it's also hard i
appreciate everything about it it's so
authentic
that's why that's why i knew it yeah
that guy has the same outfit as ryu from
streets
yeah like i would love to go do that but
i'd also love to go like fight in one fc
and do like soccer kicks and knees to
downwards
that wasn't some of those so one fc dude
i just saw uh
get knocked out with the knee brandon
oh yeah i mean i was like one
championship it's the big one it's a big
organization in asia it's like the ufc
of asia although ufc still oh that music
tape works yeah yeah i mean state worked
for him but they have a different set of
rules where he can kick
or knee down opponent on the ground so
it's almost pride rules
do you think that that would be a good
thing to add in the ufc
i do with all the guys from dagestan
coming because then they're going to get
more finishes
but it also like helps the grapplers get
finishes yes so in other words but what
about
i don't i don't like well again like
to entice the fan base if you have all
these wrestlers taking over from dagger
state yeah they're going through it's
only matter they're going to be
corrected
they're all going to be like a 55
pounder they're islam
monster so imagine if he if he can get
you down
and then figure out how to get an
underhook and get
generate power off his knees so you can
get
finishes yeah you're gonna get finishes
which the fans want to see
they can't understand it so the head as
well no no problem yeah yeah
i just don't like this i don't like
being like i used to be better i don't
know i don't like kids no rules
i don't like kids should still be
allowed you know that's just me it's too
vicious
you want all you want all dude like old
school ufc man i wish
i wish they would have never changed
just to get
yeah i get it i mean i get it i just
wish they'd at least allow the ghee
again if you see teeth flying
you know yeah they haven't allowed the
ghee since like what ufc
like eight i mean yeah guys were in geez
they would have
a boxing glove on they'd have shoes you
know hard chambers
but a lot of jiu-jitsu training geese
yeah yeah but that's the jitsu the
sports in the key
you got it okay yeah that's like the but
then no no
there's no just as big yeah it's not
bigger now i think nobody got big
because of mma you know
eddie brought with 10th planet that's
like the nogi that's no matter yeah like
they they train like exclusively
it's like i think it's only known yeah
10 plans only nogi
do you mind do you train jujitsu or dogi
both both yeah um
if you want to get better you you should
be like so my son's in jitsu
and my girl's like oh well should you no
yeah no no if he wants to learn the
actual jiu-jitsu like the fundamentals
you start with the ghee then once you
realize how hard it is in the ghee and
you take the key off
your skill set's so much higher oh i
think like no
guys with two nogi is more basic and
more sport and oriented for sure like
regular jiu jitsu with the ghee is more
like realistic and self-defense because
if you think about it
a ghee is just a jacket pants and a belt
yep and that's why rogan doesn't wear
[ __ ]
ties you know that right he refuses
where attack is too easy to choke
oh i'm sorry are you in what fast and
furious nine
like who's choking out with a tie bro
are you jumping out of the helicopter
he doesn't really think that oh yeah oh
yeah
i mean you know my mother used to say
don't wear a scarf
and i was like why because if it gets
caught in a bus door
you will be dragged down the street or
an escalator she'd be right and i'm like
i'm not on i'm not taking the bus we're
there
you know also
like who wears a scarf where it's tied
that tight around their neck yeah
we were in the scarf from like uh
christmas story where it's like yeah
when you hear all these stories the
little girl got her thing and she you
know i've never heard that
like for the last decade if something
like that actually happened it would be
all over the internet scarf i'm aware
so your dream is to get to something
like that level or at least what about
like uh lfa
in you know in los angeles which is a
big organization
if they gave me a shot yeah like i said
i've already got an offer from fury fc
so once i get down to like 264
265 i'm yeah cause yeah because the
commission's gonna make you cut to 65.
yeah yeah oh really oh yeah there's no
super heavyweight
oh yeah yeah yeah that's the the thing
that sucks about like like the amateurs
have it they have super and ultra
heavyweight but then like you get to
pros and it doesn't go past
heavy weight because there's not enough
there's not enough guys
240 terrible example who else yeah big
dude
brock lesnar would probably be about
less don't have to cut to 65. yeah
francis sagano has a cut to six what
about that one they call bigfoot
they all have to catch 65. yeah like i'm
gonna i'm gonna try to get down to it
because i
wouldn't be around that weight you know
i can get down there and walk around
that way if i'm training i mean if you
walked around at
70 something you know 74 and then cut
nine pounds
yeah that'd be easy yeah but yeah i'd
rather just walk around that way because
i haven't
gotten down to like walking around like
walking around at two six in other words
like i'm 265
all the time instead of having to like
dehydrate myself throughout
the fight way better yeah
the reason the ufc does is because
there's just not enough big guys like
there's no
there's nothing if they had a super
heavyweight division it would be like
four guys in it
yeah i mean you're trying to get it yeah
there really ain't i mean
look at you get guys like that it's like
all freak show fights like that one they
just didn't like russia or whatever or
was like the 550 pound
yeah dude pride used to do something the
woman who enjoys
yeah you you yeah yeah
wow what are you talking about woman
beats the [ __ ] out of this like an
mma fighter and this dude no [ __ ] she
beats the fight yeah real fight no fight
real fight bro it's one beats five i'm
sorry
going back uh you said that they don't
allow the ghee in the ufc anymore what
was the reason behind that
um it's kind of like a double-edged
sword okay you know
people can grab it it's an advantage too
it's it's it's just
like a lounge that's actually kind of
why i wore it and streaming because i
can and two because it the friction
it's an advantage yeah sure you know
when when they're all sweaty and stuff
and you're trying to get under hooks and
like maintain them or something
no ghee dude you're slipping off yeah
it's yeah
i actually had a fight at a tournament
and
the way they were doing is like you win
your weight class and then you fight
everyone who won their weight class for
like a belt
and i was fighting this dude who was
like 70 pounds lighter than me
but he was all sweaty and was wearing a
tank top
and uh every time i tried to do one of
my judo throws or something slide
right off so then i was like are we
allowed to wear ghee is just
just curious so they were like yeah you
can but i mean they're allowed to use it
against you if you do it's like
yeah good luck yeah all right cool so i
started wearing that in fact that's
i started wearing this ghee in fact i've
worn this ski that's why i wore this key
for that detail fight because i've worn
it in
like the sport mma sparring tournaments
all the time i was like well if i'm
gonna wear a ghee and stand out this is
the one
who's your who's your favorite fighter
all the time man
that's like a list besides brian cowan
yeah
i've never seen this guy fight but he's
a hell of a comedian he was one of my
favorite guys on mad tv
man yeah like him and nicole sullivan
were like my two favorites
i can throw hands and feet yeah i'm
gonna have to see that one of these
i'm about to see one of these days
my speed is stupid at 54 watch let's get
some mitch you should go fight wade
i i i come sign up for street beasts and
fight weight out and i didn't fast
40 plus i thought about the master
division yeah
yeah wade adams wa that dude will fight
you ryan how old are you
i know i don't know i want to say i want
to see you i just wish you were making
money man i don't know it's frustrating
yeah well i mean you know
but you're oh yeah i'm happy with the
exposure
and you know scarves and all them have
been great like they paid for me to go
out to virginia and everything and
you know so with this offer that you're
getting what will
money start coming yeah it's a pro fury
fc is a pro organization
okay so you'll get a legit organization
yeah yeah
that's good yeah getting paid the fight
is a
[ __ ] like big deal yeah that's a big
deal it's really hard it means you're a
professional yeah yep
yeah it's a lot of a lot of fun now if
you get an injury
uh in this fight in july what happens is
it on you there's no insurance right
um nope yeah i mean it's rather sturdy
but yeah i've i've actually never gotten
really injured
where i need to go to the doctor in one
of these fights and i really don't uh
you know don't no disrespect to big
smile i don't see him hurting me enough
to
yeah like yeah to go this god
[ __ ] he's just this guy don't give
him a [ __ ]
honestly well i didn't no nobody has
fought big smile has ever gone to
hospital
i'll tell you that yeah i mean yeah and
it doesn't it isn't i don't think it's
because
just because he doesn't hit that hard
it's because i think
he understands that we're not getting
paid for this and he just does what he
needs to to win
oh god it's not like yeah yeah yeah that
makes i mean i'm not over here trying to
break people's arms either you know i
mean like yeah i'll get it where you
know i know you're gonna attack but i'm
not
i'm not trying to pull a uh no it is no
one's trying to like
frank mayor nogueira rodrigo have you
done any research on how to suck down
the weight where it's easier um
i mean not really i'm trying to do what
i did last time i dropped all that
weight
pretty much training full time and
keeping the carbs out of my diet
yeah that's amazing remember that time
you tried to get down to 205 i remember
that
it lasted about four days you get down
to 225 though yeah
yeah ooh what's that something good too
i've never been to
high school too big it's too big i get
down 225 though
yeah i think when you when you did that
metamorphosis already
no it's 226 where yeah
told me to say hi i love jen yeah man i
hang out in his twitch stream like every
week
oh no he told me i'm like his official
uh chat fighter now oh i love it man i
worked
on the kingdom yeah yeah he was a guest
on there he's great
yeah he told me he told me to tell his
people hi you mind doing some current
events with us
uh sure what do you got for us jim first
one yeah
okay so yesterday a fan threw popcorn at
russell
westbrook while he was getting into the
locker room because he had
a hamstring injury and he is saying that
the nba needs to protect
their players better i think that same
day
the player tae young was spat at as well
jesus christ damn so i don't know what
it is but fans seem very rowdy
yo all you guys
you're a fan you make no money you gotta
find that guy yeah
i know you don't care about hockey but
there was one time where a fan
someone terry o'reilly clicked the
boston bruins was in the penalty box and
i know he went out yeah fans were
throwing stuff at him so he climbed out
of the penalty box
into the sands and beat the [ __ ] out of
the fan that's fantastic that's how you
that's how it should be right
i just watched my hands to the palace
again today yeah with the
run test i mean yeah that's that's
really that's really rude i mean you're
you're there to watch a game it's a
sport things happen you shouldn't be
getting mad at athletes
but i guarantee you they won't do it as
much if the if there's gonna be banning
for life
yeah i mean for life or they're
definitely definitely needs to be
you throw it and the athlete does
something that's on you yeah
you wouldn't do that on the street to
wrestle over there
on the other hand too though it could
have been a lot worse than popcorn yeah
but [ __ ] that guy but yeah now excuse me
that dude for doing that it was on a hot
dog
or you know a cup of something that
looks like beer but probably
recycled beer you know some people don't
want to walk to the bathroom yep
i came off stage with caroline's one
time and i was new comic i
i did all right i didn't do well and as
i left the guy goes ah
this kind of like rough looking kind of
time dude and he threw a straw
like that that's hilarious it may seem
like a little thing
no dude especially if you're bombing
it's like
hey you know my temper like i'm a good
guy but if i lose i
i saw red and i i remember i got off and
i went
i go maybe i'll stick my fingers in his
eyes
i might [ __ ] him i was like i'm gonna do
something to him that he can never he
can't walk away from i was so angry i
was like
i was like it's worth the jail time and
then i kept going yeah and then
what the mc [ __ ] kind of moved me
along
and then i i i waited for him warm
outside
and my friend who i don't even know the
[ __ ] thing goes what are you doing
this is the craziest thing
you beat him up you know i've never been
that angry oh i but you know how you get
so yeah you're just like
so disrespectful [ __ ] but it was just
a straw it was ah
so oakland the city of oakland has
officially made may 19th
paul mooney day oh he's the great legend
legend used to write for richard pryor
monster chappelle show laugh actor's
doing something for him today yeah
i remember watching him on chapel show
all the time yeah and didn't suffer
fools and
i i i spent some time around paul okay
and it was even when i was
a certain age and he was just like just
like
there was always like a just be aware
that i've been
he's a tiger through this yeah like and
don't you know
and i i actually i saw somebody say what
what is your what do you do
oh no and and he goes are you in the
business
business yeah look it up yeah i don't
blame him
a legend yeah
[Laughter]
okay so chris hemsworth posted this
photo of himself with his son
oh and it's really cute but
everyone's making fun of his legs yeah
his brother got on there and went
miss leggett leg day huh you keep
skipping leg day
he's just the anger it might be the
angle it's definitely the egg [ __ ]
people are just making the fun of the
person he's
flexing the [ __ ] out of his arm but
forgot to flex his camera his brother
said bro you've been skipping leg days
again
that might be the angle or he's just got
no it's the ain't no no he's like
he's like it's definitely the answer
he's a naturally thin guy
i think it's the angle and then the
shorts look are
kind of big so like around the thighs so
it makes his thighs look like they're
not there
no he's a big because it could also be
like he has a big butt and so when he
has the basketball shorts it just like
drapes like this yeah sometimes shorts
would do that too but he's jack you're
you've been
around sports a long time natural no
absolutely not no
because that that looks real shredded a
lot of hard work though oh yeah yeah no
matter what he's talking
about he's working his ass i do see it
in people's faces like
you you see that prolonged use in like
the rock
i mean if you pick up the look at the
rocks the most recent pictures
yeah yeah but that's and he can't be
good but he's also i don't know if that
it's the steroids i think he's also been
getting hit in the face that wrestling
stuff like that's not easy on your feet
yeah it's none of it's easy but boy oh
boy it's
it it kind of takes the all the fat out
of your face
yeah the same thing is happening to the
uh indian actor nanjiani his face is
awesome he has moon face see that's moon
face
that's different than uh chris hemsworth
he's doing this for a role yeah he's a
marvel superhero he's a superhero
good lord it's insane that's
that is such a body transformation oh
his is the biggest ever yeah
this is insane he's friends with batista
right about i don't know i saw him
in person he is a striker he's a big
person he's striking he's just huge
batista
yeah but he also has proportion like
whatever he's doing that whatever that
genetics that's
good [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] look at that i saw a
video of batista getting like this
purple belt and jiu jitsu or something
and that dude was like dwarfing everyone
else yeah he's
enormous oh yeah he's just walking
through while they're whipping him with
their belts
because that's like how you get your
belt pinned on you and jiu jitsu
gauntlet and you walk back and forth a
few times was that him and he's just
walking through it like
it's nothing oh was that him doing it i
didn't that was him walking through it i
saw that video
but he's his his face is changing yes
that's crazy it looks terrible
he looks like the guy looks like he just
woke up yeah it's a baby
yeah i'm not worried about the hair he's
just [ __ ] woken up he's not arrested
he's probably just on a ton of gears
he's doing all the bodies he's doing all
the gear also who wouldn't i don't care
yeah he's playing a superhero who gives
a [ __ ] go for it
i'm all natty okay so
uh people are taking note that aaron
rodgers was
uh found in hawaii with his girlfriend
and some friends
on vacation instead of at the voluntary
offseason workout because he wants to
get traded
he wants to leave he doesn't want to
work for them anymore so why would he
show up
also because he's also the therapy yeah
it's voluntary he's also the
mvp of the league yeah so there's going
to be some money thrown at him
uh here he has a huge contract in the
year left
how old is he yeah if i was making that
football money
didn't wasn't that far too man yeah
mid 30s 33 34 what 40 was a little old
stud 37 37. super scared
yeah yeah phenomenal what else you got
all right um i talk about someone who
looks like they're younger than they are
so bernie they finally announced
showtime do i have one
i don't know why they keep using this
picture congrats on coming out
yeah that's a long time ago isn't it no
three years ago wow four years ago
they got a lot of big names on this
there's a merrell we got dude
he's my friend custer yeah kester is my
absolute favorite our guy
mariana
al bernstein abner mares
you yup jimmy lennon jr that's gonna be
great wow
yeah yeah this is a huge it's a huge
event yeah it's a big event
i'll be doing right before so i'll do uh
weigh-in so i'll do all the campaign for
weigh-ins and i'll be on the desk during
the fight and then also
doing the uh before they walk out
interviews inside the
locker rooms hell yeah you know floyd a
little bit right
you spend some time yeah remember i
worked with him for a counter fight
yeah actually i don't watch boxing much
but i'm gonna watch that because i want
to see logan paul get the crap
i'm not a logan paul fan dude i hate the
paul brothers actually
tell me why well they're gigantic
[ __ ] you got famous doing [ __ ]
stuff to random people and
logan paul really oh japan oh the japan
yeah and that's not just because my love
for japan like you don't go to another
country yeah i don't care what country
it is and
and just start to go out of your way
intentionally to disrespect the entire
culture you find this
poke balls at random people and stuff
like that and then
like the worst thing there was the thing
in the in uh
the yeah like bro you deserve to get
every ass whooping every day
forgive him for that i don't need that
no six years ago
dude you don't disrespect a corpse like
that like that's somebody who was so
stressed by the demands of their their
life and their cultures
if they took their own life and you're
going to make a joke out of it and use
it as your thumbnail
yeah like no logan gets your ass whooped
like every day
i mean i think he i think he probably
recognized that after
oh yeah all that back no he's
apologizing i mean he's apologized but i
i don't care how much you apologize you
should have you're an adult you should
have the damn sense not to do it
he wasn't gonna wait for the paul
shouldn't have been fine now he was an
adult
he's 21. no he's my age he's 25 right
yeah
he's and that's 25 now yeah that was
what we were talking about
four years ago he's 21. that is not
going to know that
yeah that's not a dollar well you didn't
make mistakes
i don't care about leaving you you
didn't make mistakes
never did anything that dumb i didn't
here's the thing here's the thing about
i will say
i i've only hung with logan once
but i know you spent more time with him
i think you if you if you actually got
to know him i don't know his brother but
if you got to know him you'd be
surprised
how he's not what he portrays on and i
understand maybe but you know what you
you get judged by how you
you present yourself not as a kid not as
a kid but it's fine
logan's age at the time logan did that
video and i have the common sense
not i'm not like this bad mistake it was
a bad mistake
very bad taste yeah bad taste but like
he knew what he was doing that's that's
that's like
he knew what he was doing about it i
think so should he so sh how long should
we
no no no how long do that i'm
i'll probably feel satisfied after i
watch floyd mayweather tear his face off
you know part of that part of the
probably part of their appeal is that
they
that's what they do yeah they want you
that that's that's you you hey
they're the guys you love to hate i get
it now let me ask you this tree panda
but you're a floyd mayweather fan
no no i'm really not because he's too
cocky too dude and he kind of has a
reputation of like cherry picking his
fights and
like not fighting people until they're
past their prime they could have
otherwise beat them
but in this case i'm gonna be rooting
for floyd for sure
see but again that's just that that's
the perception he puts out too you know
yeah well part of being popular
nowadays is if you can become the heel
like jake paul
and you know how to work it is jake paul
the heel in this fight or is logan paul
the heel
that's right paul i'm not talking about
logan logan logan i don't think logan is
just like i'll do it
i think logan would be the i guess he's
the heel on this well i don't i haven't
seen
i haven't been following that much i
haven't seen a lot of provoca
provocation from logan did you did you
watch
did you watch the presents yeah if you
watched your head you didn't watch
that i saw okay that was
brought up like i'm gonna discipline you
for the things in japan and then that
just set
logan off and he's like well i'ma
discipline you for beating women
and then it was like off oh okay yeah
that was that yeah that was the same
press conference actually yeah yeah i
mean if we're gonna throw low blows i
mean
floyd definitely has some darker demons
than yeah he's definitely got a lot of
skeletons in his closet too for sure
would you say yeah he's definitely got a
lot of skeletons his closet too all the
skeletons all the skeletons damn
here we go i know right i'm excited yeah
you'll be great you lose i would say
thank you buddy i appreciate it without
my ruddy complexion
i i like that i like that this is
there's some real beef here
i would imagine that's some real insulin
i don't know if it's real yeah
i i think you're going to see floyd
punch his lights out
i mean that's that's what the odd makers
are saying yeah i think that's what i'm
saying
yeah but the question is is is floyd
gonna
is floyd going to try to end this as
fast as he can or is it going to go ten
rounds
that's well it's only eight rounds okay
is it gonna go that the distance or is
he gonna say you know what
uh i think he i think he toys with him
the first round just uh it
embarrassing and then second round he's
probably just gonna knock this block
around because you said that's what he
did with the connor fight
kind of just entertained it for he's
entertainer yeah
yeah but i don't think he had as much uh
i mean again i could all just be the
show you know
i don't think he had as much animosity
towards connor as he does towards logan
that's fair let's see we'll see all
right someone on instagram named the
germs
tagged brian in this multiple times many
people tag this
it's this thing for your hair check it
out
look at that what is it that's a wig
that's a wig it's a modern day toupee
holy [ __ ] he's
a good looking wait that's a twofold
how many buy me that and i'm wearing it
look how real that is holy [ __ ] that's
insane
well that guy's here is awful
wow and you can get it waterproof wow
bro how much is that what which crack is
this
i think you can see it's a wig though
it's called we are quiff man that looks
[ __ ] good yeah but it's still got the
glue
yeah that that's gotta suck oh that's
that's gotta stop never happening but
yeah i get it well too
they need you to throw on that
australian accent and you know wig in a
box
look at that because it's right mike
it's right that's not a bad option
though did you ever see that character i
do on mad tv uh
dennis in a box oh my gosh dude that was
one of the best mad teaser
kits of all time commercial for
parroting all the infomercials
you sent away for you can put your own
tooth inside really oh dude it's [ __ ]
so stupid dude yeah that's it watch this
look at how [ __ ] young i am stop
there this was such a [ __ ]
hit though when we did it everybody it
was
one of the more famous sketches and we
did a bunch of different
things but i mean that's hilarious so
whose idea was the phone sex skate
i don't remember you don't remember yeah
it wasn't mine
you remember the skin yeah it's my mom
apparently you met a girl he says it's
his future
this is the guy that says you know he
was in that the church said he was
converted i don't think that date is
straight oh well she's hot by the way so
he's not ready for that
that's his girlfriend but he also likes
men's yeah well so he went to church
instead of giving me one of the most
viral videos he gets in the moment they
have the mic
and he goes i don't like men's and him
all right so i was like what are you
doing
i'm not going to use a purse anymore
yeah i won't wear makeup
so now he's going to go but all the
comments
i mean she's not dating him no yeah i
know he's still stan hashtag still
standing she's attracted you go with
that you want
yeah uh one more just one more um
all right i kind of want to show you
this because it reminds me of me
actually
so kelly osbourne remember we saw her
picture recently yeah and everyone
thinks she had like facial surgery
uh-huh sure do you think she did or not
absolutely
so they can do fillers and they give you
so that was her before yep
and then that's her wait a minute now go
back she looks fantastic
go back first my [ __ ] god what they
can do yeah she said
here's the thing though so she's what
she looked like before and go back again
yeah but there's also like you know
makeup and pictures so she actually
talks about it
too oh yeah so it looks fantastic i got
a little bit of an education on this
because you got your lids done because i
got my lids done um what they what they
said what they i was so naive to
everything
so it's not just that they they feel
your lips you can get
filler anyway where yes so you get your
cheeks
you get your you can redo your entire
jaw yeah everybody under
40 understand i i i was totally happy
man
let me i like how you just go
get everybody everybody knows what's
going on
not me dude yeah i know he said you know
you you know actually
not this guy but a lot of people let's
not judge because you got blast surgery
that's not judge yeah but that's because
i couldn't see
you now you can see you could you could
though i couldn't do it now i can see
what a waste of money he could use that
for his [ __ ] car you dude
listen dude no you can buy a new car
probably yeah right
i'll show you before and after the real
shitty gummy bear i can tell she's had
her her mouth has been
watch out play and then you see her talk
i'm a fan of her i don't care what she
is she looks gorgeous
right now maybe she just lost some
weight too that's the way it's awesome
that you guys are all talking about
she's so brilliant because
i'm always really honest and really
upfront about what i've done to my body
and who i am and i have not
had plastic surgery i've never done
anything to my face
other than a couple of injections in my
lips
and in my forehead here i do not lie but
thank you for the compliment
but that is plastic surgery are the
injections i mean
she didn't go under the knife no no it's
a little different yeah it's a little
different
i don't think she's done like what kylie
jenner no no no no
like if kylie made this video like get
the [ __ ] out of here all right so this
is me
don't worry about who i'm with but okay
i work weird flex i worked on a song
with
will sparrow and john c ryan look at my
face here right you see my cheeks
remember i told you i got botox
so you can see my face there and then
this is me wait hold on jenny there gin
i know i was lean here but then this is
me look like babies
see how much it changed my actual yeah i
see what you're saying yeah so it's just
from botox
wow so the muscle if you do that how
often you do that once a year now
and it makes your face skinny the
muscles that are here the master muscles
you're always chewing so you get built
up does it hurt to do it
it's fine
hey i got big cheeks no dude you guys
look normal you guys look proportional
me the size you guys are doing your face
cat uh
no i'm too afraid that you don't have a
your mom's pretty too when she's older
so you're good with technology
like now and only like 20 years from now
i can't imagine what the [ __ ] oh my god
a lot of young girls are doing uh botox
what'd you say
a lot of younger girls are doing botox
like early 20s are doing preventative
work oh yeah
if they get any wrinkles fix it with a
[ __ ] yeah they don't want the what do
they call it crows
feet they don't want their lines on
their feet i know actors that have
gotten and
now i know what to look for they can't
move i'm talking about them yeah they're
facing it
your face isn't moving when you [ __ ]
fall
that's fantastic i'm just old school i'm
like uh yeah you're not old school
though
because you got i had two procedures you
got your hair done
yeah that's all i liked how he judges
these other outfits
he went under the knife no no he just
got plastic surgery in the box yeah yeah
i only had it himself but i couldn't i
couldn't see
yeah whatever it is all right man well
street brandon we love you man yeah
thanks for coming on
your car issues we'll get that situated
yeah that's got one more thing to say
real quick i had a shout out on my team
shinigami khan the oni
uh savage able darkness and our two new
members annie on oleron and
uh apex predator
yeah did you get emotional just now yeah
oh you're doing it i couldn't tell a
little bit because man it's kind of
crazy that i'm actually
that's awesome doing all this and
actually to shout out my street beast
fighters oh i love it yeah yeah that's
so cool
well you work your ass let us know about
that fight because if we're not on tour
we will be oh yeah for sure i will
definitely
i'll miss you brian's uh yeah my
thanks again for having me on yeah yeah
of course oh [ __ ] yeah
hey come see me in toledo this weekend
uh chappelle will be in oklahoma city
oklahoma brickstown comic club june 10th
through the 12th
and then pittsburgh and raleigh
north carolina will be added on there
but then denver september 30th through
the 2nd
to get to fatkz.com as you're listening
as you're listening this right now this
airs on friday all new
thick boy gear thickboy.com uh go to my
social media wherever with thinkboy.com
for all the new swag
come see me tonight in toledo at the
funny bone
no actually i'll be there thursday
friday saturday but yeah tonight and
then saturday and then san antonio texas
lol
june 3rd 4th 5th let's go albany new
york me and dove david off at the funny
bone june 18 19.
philadelphia pennsylvania helium june 25
26 27
come get some come get some and then
next week june 4th and 5th
skyline comedy club in appleton
wisconsin and then july 15th through the
17th
magooby's joke house in baltimore
maryland i got to change it because
yeah dude get that merch rolling brother
i'm glad you can make it down man yeah
thank you so much man we're fans here
thanks for having me
yeah if we can make it man we'll be at
your fight dude yeah for sure
looking forward to it brother much
success man all right we're out all
right